[Music]
all right so as you all know by now over
the weekend comedian Roseanne Barr
tweeted out some outrageous not funny by
her own admission inappropriate
over-the-line remarks about former obama
aide Valerie Jarrett in response we all
know now that ABC has cancelled the
reboot of Roseanne the sitcom tonight
I'm going to respond to Roseanne bars
tweet and I'll also highlight what is a
sad but all too obvious double standard
in the country where it appears that
only conservatives are held accountable
for their words their reactions while
those on the left never seem to face
consequences for outright racism bigotry
or sexism and that's tonight's important
mini monologue all right we know this
week Roseanne Barr she rightly
apologized for her comments terrible
comments about Valerie Jarrett she went
on to say that no one should defend her
in light of what happened
Roseanne was right to apologize but I
would argue we all have to look at this
moment and do better as a country in
other words we've got to respect all
races all Creed's all backgrounds
Roseanne is a public figure her public
comments did in fact hurt innocent
people and she is facing consequences
for her actions now she could say it on
her own time but ABC has their own
decision making what they want to do we
also should all feel bad a lot of
innocent people lost their jobs in all
of this they have families they have
mortgages they have rent payments they
have car payments they have other
expenses college kids to worry about
now of course Roseanne is not the first
public figure though to make outrageous
comments and she even admits she has
been held rightly accountable so many
despicable comments though and actions
from those on the Left appear to go
completely unnoticed there's a huge
double standard in fact many get a free
pass no matter what they say or what
they do including a former writer that
actually is on Roseanne show commedia
Wanda Sykes before the show was
cancelled member Sykes announced that
she was quitting the show to protest
Roseanne Barr is tweet but Sykes herself
has issued outrageous extremely racial
tweets including this one white people
they don't steal wallets they still
countries and of course Sykes never
faced any career-ending backlash from
that tweet and let's not forget about
another ABC employee are all friends
Jimmy Kimmel
remember he was on Comedy Central he
often even dressed up in blackface take
a look at this hello everybody out there
a TV town this is call Malone up the
Utah Jazz here to tell you about call
Malone home state
Louisiana sometime at night call below
look up in sky and say what the hell
going on up there the UFO live on
another planet phone and whole like et
call Malone read on TV about white
people getting deducted by alien now
home alone never see no flying saucer
his self but if he do that's gonna be a
spooky time now ABC CEO Bob Iger well he
puts Jimmy Kimmel on night after night
after night that's not all
can't forget about Kimmel's pretty
despicable disgusting extremely sexist
gets that he did might remember this
welcome to Hollywood would you like to
have sex with me do you like that sex
with me sorry no please I'm begging you
I think you enjoy it big guy
yeah and unit is relatively small right
right right
[Applause]
you have ten seconds to then guess what
is in my pants
you ready set go you should use two
hands two hands didn't make a fine wife
there's no one at ABC Bob Iger Disney or
outraged outraged at all by any of that
then you of course you have joyless
Behar on ABC's The View remember she
attacked the vice president vice
president Mike Pence why because his
Christian faith take a look at this
what's was interesting is that she said
that Jesus tells Mike Pence things to
say well obviously she was around I
think when you have a Mike Pence that
now sort of puts this religious veneer
on things and calls people Values Voters
I think we're in a dangerous situation
look I'm Catholic I'm a faithful person
but I don't know that I want my vice
president
well speaking in tongues one thing to
talk to Jesus
it's another thing when Jesus talks to
you exactly
[Applause]
to illness if I'm not correct I don't
hearing voices my question is can he
talk to Mary Magdalene without his wife
in the room no really
mental illness if you're a Christian
behar was eventually forced to apologize
but only after weeks of outrage from any
viewers she still works for ABC next up
there's good old Keith Olbermann his
back short-tempered Trump 18 left his
pundit ABC's Bob Iger just rehired him
on ESPN and you might remember Olbermann
went on a number of vile tweet storms
against President Trump at one point
against him and his daughter tweeting
tell your racist white supremacist
neo-nazi father to get the bleep out of
our society over in targeting the
president former Arizona Sheriff Joe
Arpaio quote you and POTUS can go bleep
yourselves you racist Nazi bleep yeah I
heard just hired him to go back to ESPN
good luck with that now we turn our
attention to NBC news last night they
were in a special entitled everyday
racism in America all right one of the
hosts that will feature joy Reid you
might remember read recently came under
fire for outrageous blog posts she
denied the allegations claiming without
proof that the internet had been hacked
and the firestorm completely goes away
everyone on the left they just accepted
what was really a bizarre explanation
NBC also frequently features there he is
the Reverend Al Sharpton on issues of
race and social justice the same al
Sharpton you may remember set all these
things
[Applause]
[Music]
he works for NBC which also frequently
features Alec Baldwin in order to make
fun of the president on Saturday Night
Live despite Baldwin's well you've got a
temper problem remember this did you
hear what I said
yeah answer me yes or no yeah you're
here when my wife and my kid come in
here you're the big problem you know
that don't you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he works for Bob Iger - at ABC
apparently meanwhile over at HBO the
left is quick to throw temper tantrum
when Bill Maher speaks out against
Islamic extremism but pretty much laughs
and applauds when Moore makes comments
like these take a look a lot of us
thought all Ivanka's gonna be our saving
grace you know when he's about to nuke
Finland or something she's gonna walk
into the bedroom and you know yeah daddy
daddy
don't do it Johnny really okay and look
up let's look at someone else's long
been in the public eye screwy louis
farrakhan the year's Congressional Black
Caucus they hid this picture they had it
before the election in 2008 Farrakhan
with Barack Obama to shield Obama for
criticism given farah khan's racist and
anti-semitic past including some of
these classic insanity comments here the
jews don't like Farrakhan
so they call me hidden well that's a
good name Hitler was a very great man
The Satanic Jews that control everything
and mostly everybody because you see
white people deserve to die and they
know so they think it's us coming to do
Caucasian means we bloody week boom
stale face that pale but the Indian
called a pale man
so as the mainstream media expressed
outrage that Obama associated with that
person or the American people being
deceived they purposely hit a picture
the two of them together it's right
there on your screen
oh then of course we got Bernardine
Dohrn Bill Ayers or of course Reverend
Wright the pastor of the Church of Gd
America let me be clear I will never
ever call for any boycotts or anybody to
be fired or any show to be canceled you
have the power to turn the dial but it
is important to point out what is a
blatant left-wing double standard in
this country and perhaps the person who
summed it up best was the White House
press secretary today Sarah Sanders when
she said this take a look the
president's pointed to the hypocrisy in
the media saying that the most horrible
things about this president and nobody
addresses it where was Bob iger's
apology to the White House staff for
Jamel Hill calling the President and
anyone associated with him a white
supremacist to Christians around the
world for joy bear Klein Christianity a
mental illness
where was the apology for Kathy Griffin
going on a profane rant against the
president on the view after a photo
showed showed her holding president
Trump's decapitated head and where was
the apology from Bob Iger for ESPN
hiring Keith Olbermann after his
numerous expletive laced tweets
attacking the president as a Nazi and
even expanding over man's role after
that attack against the president's
family this is a double standard that
the president speaking about no one is
defending her comments they're
inappropriate but that's what the point
that he was making well said Sarah
Sanders and I said at the beginning of
this monologue let's think about this it
is time for all Americans regardless of
whatever give you political affiliation
is yeah we all need to do better
we know all need to hold ourselves our
friends accountable for words and
actions we need to be one nation one
people this country is gonna succeed or
fail together if we're attack it's all
of us attack we're supposed to be the
United States of America regardless of
race creed color national origin my
religion does teach me all created all
of us in this by the same God in His
image we can all do so much better we've
got to be the United States of America
that should be everybody's gold too many
people have died and sacrificed for all
of us to have liberty and freedom and we
owe that to every single solitary child
in this country